RYAN MATSUMOTO: Hi.
My name is Ryan, and this is an
introduction to Google Cloud.
This video is great for anyone
new to Google Cloud who's
interested in learning more.
In the next few minutes, we'll
talk about what Google Cloud is
and how it can help
you as a developer.
Ready?
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Cloud computing is all
about getting things done
using someone else's computers.
So when you use
Google Cloud, you're
getting things done
using Google's computers.
Google Cloud lets you build in
host applications, store data,
and analyze data, all
in Google's highly
scalable and reliable
computing infrastructure.
Google's data centers, which are
located all around the world,
house the compute, storage,
and networking capabilities
that power Google's own
products and services,
including Search,
Gmail, and YouTube.
With Google Cloud,
Google is basically
sharing these
computing resources
with developers like yourself
so you can build and run
applications using Google's
computing infrastructure.
One of the key advantages
of cloud computing is scale.
Take an example of a retailer
looking to set up a database
to help manage their
inventory, pricing,
and demand across thousands
of stores internationally.
One of the biggest
challenges in retail
is figuring out how to handle
massive seasonal spikes
during the holiday season.
If you were to try
to set up and manage
your own on-premise
database, it would likely
be expensive and inefficient to
provision additional hardware
to do so.
You'd have to pay
large upfront costs
to set up the additional
database infrastructure, which
you wouldn't even need
for most of the year.
You'd also need to
worry about implementing
your own complicated
database charting strategy,
managing backups, meeting
performance requirements,
and securing the entire thing.
Or you could use a
fully managed database
like Cloud Spanner, where
all this is managed for you.
Google Cloud would
manage scaling for you
so that you only pay for the
data storage you actually need.
Google Cloud has hundreds of
different products and services
that solve problems
shared by developers
all around the world.
While it would take me hours
to talk about every single one,
here's a look at
several different ways
that these products can
help you as a developer.
One of the first
things you may want
to do when trying
out a cloud platform
is hosting your code
and applications.
Compute Engine gives you
virtual machines that
run in Google Data centers.
With Cloud Run, you can deploy
containerized applications
on a fully managed
serverless platform.
And with App Engine, you can
deploy highly scalable web apps
and other back-end services.
Next, you probably want
to store data, some of it
structured, some
of it unstructured.
Cloud Storage is perfect for
unstructured data like images,
videos, and audio files.
Cloud SQL hosts Google-managed
versions of MySQL, Postgres,
and SQL Server.
You can run the same
relational databases
you know without all the
hassles of self-management.
Cloud Firestore is a NoSQL
document-based realtime
database.
It's popular for use
cases like gaming,
where it's very
important for users
to have the most up-to-date
version of data in real time.
Then there are AI and
machine learning tools,
which can be helpful if you are
an experienced machine learning
developer, but also if you
know zero machine learning,
but still want to take advantage
of Google's AI technologies
for your own applications.
Suppose you have images--
lots of images in your
application-- and you
want to enhance your
application by knowing
what's in each image.
Vision AI provides an API
that will take an image
and run object detection,
find landmarks, extract text,
and more, allowing
your users to use
that information in your app.
Or maybe you want to
analyze user comments
in your application using
natural language processing.
With Cloud Natural Language,
you can analyze a piece of text
and get information about its
entities, sentiment, syntax,
and content categorization.
And if you want to
build and deploy
your own machine
learning models,
you can do that as well.
Vertex AI is Google
Cloud's unified machine
learning platform for training,
hosting, and managing machine
learning models.
One great aspect of Google
Cloud is the opportunity
to seamlessly integrate
multiple products to suit
your own unique use case.
Say that you're building
a new social networking
site for dogs.
You could start out by
storing profile photos
in Cloud Storage.
Then you could set up a
Cloud Firestore database
to store other profile
information, like dog
names, locations, and hobbies.
Next, you could use Vision
AI to detect objects
in each photo, like balls,
stuffed animals, and bones.
These machine
learning-powered data insights
might help your users
find other furry friends
with similar interests.
And finally, you could
deploy your application
to the web using Cloud Run.
This would make it easy for
your app to scale automatically
as you gain more users.
So there you have it,
an overview of what
Google Cloud is and some
of the different products
you may be interested
in as a developer.
Stay tuned for more episodes
of Google Cloud Essentials,
where we'll cover the Google
Cloud Console, the Google Cloud
SDK, the free trial,
key use cases, and more.
I can't wait to see what
you build with Google Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]